avant de répondre à la question tu vas
te présenter je suis je viens de puis
monifier
toi tu viens d'où
je viens de Philippe
je viens du crâne quand je suis ici
dans la classe comme enseignant en
francisation Olivier kenfac bouge
beaucoup j'ai mis on fait des mimes on
prend des situations authentique vous
l'avez vu c'est comme du théâtre et là
il se retrouve en 5 années j'ai eu une
clientèle différente au fil du temps
cette année c'est beaucoup plus
diversifié avec la même passion il fait
maintenant face à un plus grand nombre
d'élèves arrivé comme demandeur d'asile
il y en a vraiment qui ont vécu des
situations d'arrêt
les transites pas d'autres pays ils
viennent par le chemin Roxane ils savent
pas ils ont vécu des traumas ils ne
s'adaptent pas facilement je dois
d'abord créer un lien affectif il faut
qu'il m'accepte commencera tu prends le
Bescherelle si tu en as besoin cette
école de côté neige contre quatre
classes d'accueil on y enseigne le
français aux nouveaux arrivants depuis
longtemps mais il y a maintenant de
nouveaux défis je constate quand même
d'énormes différences entre ce que
j'avais connu et la réalité
de cette année particulièrement il y a
eu une pause due à la pandémie mais là
on se retrouve aussi avec des gens qui
doivent quitter le pays leur pays parce
qu'ils ne peuvent plus rester alors là
on a des des familles qui arrivent et
qui ont besoin de tout il y a eu des
interruptions dans la scolarisation ils
arrivent avec rien souvent juste un
petit sac alors ben il faut trouver des
sacs à dos il faut s'occuper de la
nourriture ou est-ce qu'ils vont comment
ils vont manger pour inscrire les
enfants à l'école les nouveaux arrivants
doivent avoir une adresse fixe
du Canada
avec 4 enfants Valérie valbrunn espère
que ses filles puissent enfin commencer
l'école au Québec la grande majorité de
nos nouvelles inscriptions c'est des
demandeurs d'asile les pays qu'on a le
plus présentement c'est le Mexique c'est
la Colombie CIC et l'Ukraine donc c'est
des pays où on a des demandeurs d'asile
soit par le chemin Roxane ou des
demandeurs d'asile Ukrainiens le service
des inscriptions du centre de service
scolaire de Montréal le plus grand au
Québec est occupé comme jamais en deux
mois 1500 nouveaux élèves se sont
ajoutés un record en si peu de temps 82
classes là c'est l'équivalent lors d'une
centaine d'enseignants que l'on doit
trouver mais au niveau de la pénurie de
personnel c'est ce qui nous inquiète le
plus chaque nouvelle inscription nous
demande d'ouvrir de nouvelles classes
donc on a plus de place dans les classes
existantes donc ça allonge le processus
depuis quelques années le cssdm a une
équipe d'employés dédiés au soutien des
familles
issus de l'immigration et qui donne
aussi un appui au personnel des écoles
on peut pas prévoir un moyen ou à court
terme qui va y avoir une baisse de la
population scolaire immigrante donc
c'est vraiment des forces qu'on est en
train de se construire là pour les
années à venir est-ce que c'est une
phrase simple ou une phrase complet à
Saint Pascal Bellon l'accueil va bien
au-delà de l'école grâce à des agents de
service social comme rime walleg dans
l'église voisine des parents viennent
choisir des vêtements chauds on part des
besoins de base on parle de dépannage
vestimentaire mais on peut aller au-delà
là cette précieuse ressource veille
aussi sur ceux qui doivent encore
attendre avant de pouvoir fréquenter
l'école on a reçu 35 demandeurs d'asile
d'origine que c'était une cohorte qui
sont dans les hôtels depuis quatre mois
qui n'arrivent pas à trouver un logement
donc pas de scolarisation avec les pour
les enfants et on a réussi nous au
centre notre centre de service scolaire
de préparer avec nos collègues
conseillers pédagogiques à l'accueil une
trousse avec des autistes simples avec
des jeux simples pour ses enfants
[Musique]
c'est beaucoup plus aidant pour moi
parce que par le passé je l'avais pas
mais ce qui manque c'est d'autres
ressources au sein de l'école après
avoir renseigné au Cameroun et en Europe
pendant des années Monsieur Olivier
prend le temps qu'il faut avec cette
nouvelle facette de l'accueil ce sont
des élèves qui arrivent avec des bagages
je les aide à défaire ces bagages
d'abord linguistique et culturel je
m'appuie sur celui-là pour mettre une
couche de français
ici Anne-Louise despaty Radio-Canada
Montréal